dames 1
le placement fait
c'est une opération de visibilisation
des populations non pris en charge par
l'état
donc ça fait un mois qu'on se fait
trimballer par la police chasser dans
tout paris donc on a décidé de faire une
action de visibilisation de façon à ce
que l'état prenne ses responsabilités et
aujourd'hui en fait ce qu'ils font c'est
qu'ils nous emmène la police il embarque
des papas il est contrôlé les et ils
vont les emmener en centre de rétention
pour une partie d'entre eux c'est tout
simplement inadmissible
pour mieux
il va
ces populations sont lassés des gens qui
veulent demander l'asile ils ont même
plus la possibilité de déposer une
demande d'asile personnes ils sont
totalement invisibilité chassés de paris
et nous on est là pour essayer aussi de
2,2 les visibiliser de dire qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ces populations
ouais
le club
là
ça fait des semaines que la ville de
paris demande une opération conjointe de
mise à l'abri avec les services de
l'état je regrette évidemment qu'on en
vienne là et je constate avec beaucoup
de colère qu'aujourd'hui la préfecture
de police envisage une opération
d'évacuation sèche sans solution
d'hébergement à l'appui
tours
m
alors
d'un point
toi mon
vous pouvez aller combat les tous à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
non